no it's been said over and over again we
all remember where we were on that day
and I was 12 I was 12 years old on 9/11
and and it was that day you know when
you're a kid and this was happening to
so many New York kids that was the day
that our definition of hero changed
where it was no longer the things we saw
on television or the characters we saw
in movies but forever for the rest of
our lives our definition of hero changed
to the firefighters police officers and
first responders that showed up the
people who gave their lives their time
their health for others they define
heroism for others and in that spirit we
have a responsibility to say for heroism
and for acts of heroism we will be for
you there then we will be there for you
now and we will be there for you
tomorrow no matter what no matter what
that is what the meaning of the Victims
Compensation Fund really is that is what
we are telling the American people that
heroism and American heroism is
something that we will always value and
whether it was an injury or a disability
that happened physically on the day of
the attacks